[Musik] hallo zusammen wir machen heute eine
Mandarinen Quarktorte die wird sehr leichte
Magen liegen und ist auch sehr sehr leicht
in der Zubereitung ich starte jetzt mit meinem
berühmten blitzboden ich liebe den wenn es
schnell gehen muss und dafür nehme ich jetzt
die Küchenmaschine ihr könnt auch euer Handrührgerät
verwenden aber die Küchenmaschine schlägt
natürlich alles noch ein bisschen fluffiger
auf und dann habt ihr einen fluffigeren und
etwas höheren Boden hier habe ich jetzt die
Eier reingegeben da kommt jetzt noch Zucker
mit dazu ich schreibe euch übrigens wie immer
alle ganz genauen Mengenangaben hier unten
in der Videobeschreibung auf damit dieses
Video nicht so lange hat mich und so langweilig
wird aber ich gestalte die Videos immer eben
so wie ich glaube dass sie mir auch als Zuschauer
am besten gefallen würden aber schreibt mir
gerne immer euer Feedback in die Kommentare
jetzt gebe ich dir auch schon direkt Vanilleextrakt
mit dazu und dann wird das bei hoher Geschwindigkeit
so 23 Minuten lang richtig schön dick cremig
geschlagen [Musik] also bei mir war es jetzt
noch eineinhalb Minuten schon fertig ich vergesse
halt auch immer dass die Maschine ultra-leistungsstark
ist und ich dadurch immer eigentlich nur die
Hälfte an Zeit brauche die ich euch vorgebe
falls ihr aber ein Handrührgerät verwendet
dann haltet euch so an drei bis vier Minuten
guck mal so muss die Masse aussehen also richtig
schön fluffig und hell da gebe ich jetzt
Öl mit dazu ich nehme immer das Öl da das
Öl ich nehme immer das Öl was ich gerade
da habe also das habe ich gerade Rapsöl da
könnt auch Sonnenblumenöl nehmen Olivenöl
jetzt nicht so geil glaube ich hier geschmacklich
was gebe ich jetzt einfach mit dazu rühre
ganz kurz alles noch mal unter also wirklich
nur für ein paar Sekunden und dann könnt
ihr parallel hier schon mal Backpulver und
Mehl einfach schon mal miteinander verrühren
und dann hin zu sieben dann ist die Masse
auch schon fertig [Musik]
ich habe jetzt hier meine 24 cm Springform
und ich habe kein Backpapier zu Hause ehrlich
habe nur so ein kleines Fitzelchen aber es
ist gar nicht schlimm denn dadurch dass ich
jetzt in meinem Teig auch ein bisschen Fett
habe und die Springform ja sowieso eine gute
Beschichtung hat und antihaft ist kann ich
das jetzt einfach einfüllen dann kann ich
das gleich einfach wirklich super easy lösen
alles unglaublich ich habe kein Backpapier
zu Hause gibt's doch gar nicht so Streiche
sondern ein bisschen glatt dann verrate ich
euch auch schon mal die Backzeit und zwar
habe ich den Ofen vorgeheizt auf 180 Grad
Ober- und Unterhitze ganz wichtig dass du
den auch wirklich immer lange genug vorher
vorheizt damit der wirklich diese Schockstarre
bekommt und dann in aller Ruhe backen kann
so einmal schön verstreichen und dann ist
er auch eigentlich schon nach 14 bis 15 Minuten
garen danach lasse ich ihn vollständig auskühlen
aber benutzen die Zwischenzeit und machen
die leckere Quarkcreme [Musik]
[Applaus] so wir benötigen wieder ein paar
einfache Zutaten die ihr eigentlich überall
bekommt und zwar Schlagsahne am besten sollten
die Zutaten jetzt sehr sehr kalt sein ich
mache es aber anders damit ich gleich keine
Sauerei habe gebe ich jetzt erstmal Mascarpone
in meine Rührschüssel das wird eine Quarkcreme
wo ich auch ein bisschen Mascarpone Anteil
habe einfach damit die Creme schön fest wird
ihr wisst ja Quark ist immer so ein bisschen
wabbeliger Mascarpone hilft einfach beim stabilisieren
und schmeckt auch noch schön neutral also
perfekt in der Schüssel bzw sollte eigentlich
reinplappen so und da kann ich dann schon
direkt Zucker mit dazu geben für die süße
für den Geschmack habe ich mir überlegt
Vanille und Zitronenschalen Abrieb ist immer
eine schöne Kombination also einfach ein
bisschen rein bei der Zitrone drauf achten
dass sie die Schale mit verzehren könnt also
am besten eine Bio Zitrone nehmen und bitte
auf gar keinen Fall unter der gelben Schale
die weißt du noch mit reiben sonst ist die
ganze Creme total Mütter also ihr müsst
wirklich immer wieder gucken ich weiß nicht
ob man es schon sieht aber ich schreibe mal
ein bisschen genau das hier darf man nicht
mehr reiben weil sonst wird es total bitter
und dann denkt man sich ja super gekehrter
volle Rezept für die Creme entwickelt aber
eins ist super lecker wenn ihr wirklich nur
die gelbe Schale verwendet da reicht jetzt
auch nur die halbe Zitrone es muss jetzt nicht
zu zitronig werden wir gleich noch die schöne
Fruchtanlage das zeige ich euch dann im Anschluss
so da gebe ich jetzt auch schon Sahne mit
dazu ganz langsam und kann schon mal ein bisschen
verrühren aber so dass ich das erst verbindet
und dann könnt ihr immer mehr Sahne dazugeben
bis in der homogene Masse erhaltet [Musik]
also sobald gemerkt dass die Creme ein bisschen
fester wird und vor allem auch der Schneebesen
musste einzeichnet in die Creme ist es soweit
und ihr könnt Sahne fester zu geben das sorgt
einfach noch mal für die Stabilität und
ganz zum Schluss kommt Magerquark dazu und
den rührt ihr wirklich nur ganz kurz unter
aber sonst wird er zu flüssig deswegen gebe
ich den hier auch ganz zum Schluss mit rein
alles schön ausschaben und Nichts verschwinden
hier und dann wie gesagt nur noch 45 Sekunden
lang einrühren die Creme werde ich in der
Zwischenzeit kühl stellen mein Ofen hat gerade
gepiept und der Boden ist fertig der muss
jetzt erstmal auskühlen und die Creme kommt
in der Zwischenzeit dann in den Kühlschrank
[Musik] für unsere fruchteinlage brauchen
wir einen Saft eurer Wahl also das was sie
am liebsten mögt ich habe hier einfach Multivitaminsaft
genommen und nehme jetzt hier für mein Konstrukt
so nenne ich mal damit wir die fruchteinlage
gleich einfrieren können nämlich hier einfach
einen cakeboard da könnt ihr einfach irgendein
flachen Gegenstand nehmen und dann habe ich
hier noch meinen Tortenring den benutze ich
ja gleich sowieso noch zum Schichten der Torte
dann habe ich hier einfach ein bisschen Frischhaltefolie
und ich nehme da immer gerne zwei nebeneinander
damit mir dann die Fruchtanlage gleich auch
nicht ausläuft wichtig ist das ja auch eine
schöne gerade Oberfläche habt damit ihr
eben ja kein Saft irgendwie in einem Tiefkühlschrank
habt oder das irgendwie ausläuft so das könnt
ihr dann hier einfach hinlegen die Seiten
schön hochziehen wie gesagt als Auslaufschutz
so ein bisschen und dann reicht das eigentlich
auch mit unserer Vorbereitung also so ist
es eigentlich perfekt und dann habe ich hier
wie gesagt einfach nur Saft und Argentine
das ist pflanzliches Geliermittel also veganische
Geliermittel quasi wird aus eigen gewonnen
schmeckt aber überhaupt nach gar nichts also
da brauchte ich überhaupt keine Sorgen machen
ich werde das jetzt hier einfach erstmal verrühren
dann den Herd einschalten und dann zwei Minuten
sprudelt kochen lassen [Musik] die zwei Minuten
sind rum ich nehme einmal die Pfanne vom Herd
und jetzt am besten noch mal so fünf sechs
sieben Minuten ausdampfen lassen und dann
fülle ich das hier rein wie gesagt ich habe
ja Platz im Tiefkühlschrank da braucht es
nur 10 Minuten aber ihr könnt auch ganz normal
den Kühlschrank verwenden dann wird es vielleicht
20 25 oder maximal 30 Minuten je nachdem wie
kalt euer Kühlschrank eingestellt ist aber
ich weiß dass die meisten noch kein Platz
haben im Tiefkühlschrank ist auch mein tägliches
struggle aber ich habe aufgeräumt und da
ging das bei mir wie gesagt und anschließend
machen wir weiter und stellen die ganze Torte
zusammen
der spaßigste Teil beginnt okay das Backen
hat auch Spaß gemacht aber jetzt wird es
richtig cool denn wir stellen alles zusammen
ich habe mir jetzt eine hübsche Tortenplatte
ausgesucht mal gucken ob sich das beißt oder
nicht aber ich glaube es passt ganz gut ich
hätte auch ein bisschen Unterstützung hier
meine Kamera Frau Jasmin und wir gucken einfach
mal ich glaube es wird ganz gut passen aber
ich leg sowieso ein cakeboard unten drunter
damit ich notfalls auch einfacher noch mal
umstülpen kann und falls ihr kein Platz im
Kühlschrank habt ist so ein cakeboard auch
immer gut weil dann könnt ihr das ganz einfach
immer umdisponieren ohne Stress zu haben ohne
die Riesen tortenplätze noch dabei zu haben
so der Boden ist jetzt einmal drauf und jetzt
brauchen wir eigentlich noch mal unseren Tortenring
ich habe natürlich mehrere Tortenringe da
aber wenn ihr jetzt nur ein zuhause habt dass
er überhaupt nicht schlimm ist nehmt ihr
einfach die fruchteinlage raus lass die einfach
hier auf der Folie aber da könnte ich jetzt
auch noch mal mit dem Tortenring Löser an
damit ich mir die Fruchtanlage nicht rausreißen
ah geht's ja perfekt und dann nehmen wir uns
so dann nehmen wir uns eigentlich nur den
Tortenring ich mache den jetzt auch gar nicht
sauber das macht überhaupt nichts macht ihn
einfach ein bisschen größer die Torte ist
ja 24 cm groß also den Tortenring einmal
um den Boden legen hat den Vorteil dass ihr
das jetzt hier auch noch mal schön eng dran
machen könnt was habe ich jetzt für ein
Durchmesser 23,5 das heißt der Boden wird
nach dem Backen auch noch so ein bisschen
leicht zusammenschrumpfen das ist ganz normal
so und jetzt einfach die Creme zur Hälfte
hier drin verteilen glatt verstreichen dann
kommt unsere leckere fruchteinlage oben drauf
und dann kommt die restliche Creme dazu das
ganze glatt verstreichen und dann schließen
wir miteinander reden ab ihr könnt jetzt
noch mal also ich mache auch oft ohne Tortenplatte
aber damit es ein bisschen einfacher geht
könnt ihr jetzt auch noch meine Tortenplatte
die drehbar ist unten drunter tun dann habt
ihr ein bisschen einfacher
[Musik] für den Abschluss brauchen wir natürlich
Mandarinen aus der Dose und da könnt ihr
den Saft auf jeden Fall einmal abschöpfen
ich habe jetzt hier mein Saft abgewogen 250
Gramm wert das jetzt noch mal mit meinem Multivitaminsaft
einfach auffüllen auf 300 Gramm auf die müssen
wir nämlich auf jeden Fall kommen
perfekt so und außerdem schönere Farbe so
und das werde ich gleich wieder zusammen mit
Argentine das was wir gerade auch schon hatten
einmal aufkochen das Netz ist nur das Verhältnis
ein bisschen anders die Fruchtanlage musste
fester sein und dass sie muss jetzt nicht
ganz so fest sein wie gesagt ich schreibe
euch alles ganz genau unten in die Video Beschreibung
was ich jetzt aber auch schon mal vorbereitet
sind die Mandarin ich mag es halt wenn die
ein bisschen kleiner sind dann kann man später
die Torte auch ein bisschen besser durchschneiden
also einfach mit dem Messer hier so ein paar
Mal entlang gehen dann sind die halbiert oder
sogar auch gedreht und dadurch dass wir jetzt
auch den süßen Saft haben brauchen wir gar
keinen Zucker mehr so und jetzt geht's wieder
an den Herd wieder kurz verrückt das ist
klümchen frei ist und dann zwei Minuten lang
sprudeln kochen lassen [Musik] [Applaus] [Musik]
ich habe hier den Guss jetzt auch noch mal
12 13 Minuten lang auskühlen lassen denn
jetzt kommt der wirklich der warme Guss auf
die Sahne Quarkcreme und das ist wirklich
ein bisschen heikel da solltet ihr auf jeden
Fall darauf achten dass wenn ihr anfasst das
ist eigentlich nur noch ganz leicht lauwarm
ist sollte jetzt natürlich nicht fest werden
aber das wird es auch nicht also das ist eigentlich
ein ganz entspannter groß muss ich sagen
sehe ich aber erstmal kurz zur Seite ich wollte
euch nämlich noch einen Tipp geben für die
Mandarinen da könnt ihr noch mal mit einem
geschirrtor mit dem Küchentuch könntet ihr
auch machen wenn sauber ist einfach noch mal
drüber gehen und den Saft aufsaugen weil
das kontraproduktiv ist wenn der Saft jetzt
auch noch mal hier auf der Torte Austritt
das habe ich jetzt hier schon zweimal gemacht
das tritt nämlich immer wieder Saft aus daher
könnt ihr das auch ganz gut noch mal aufsaugen
und jetzt kommen die Mandarine einfach nur
auf die Torten Oberfläche dann wird das Ganze
versiegelt mit dem Bus und dann müsst ihr
die Torte für eine Stunde in den Kühlschrank
wandern [Musik] [Applaus] [Musik] mit dem
einzig wahren Hamza tasty mit haben sie und
haben sie immer gnadenlos ehrlich das ist
halt so ein Kuchen ich finde damit kann man
bei Familie Punkten ob jung oder alt ne aber
es ist so aber ganz ehrlich egal hauptsächlich
schmeckt
sehr zart sehr locker leicht also fruchtig
genau
mein Name ist es wirklich nicht gegessen
wie süß ist auch perfekt muss ich sagen
nicht so süß aber auch nicht zu wenig süß
ach ja
zu essen
aber wir verteilen natürlich auch fleißig
viele Fragen immer wo gehen die Stücke verteilen
wirklich 30 wir haben ja auch im Bekanntenkreis
Menschen um uns
herum mein Kanal links getan hast und dann
sehen wir beim nächsten Video tschüss [Musik]